KATE: Authors at Google New York
is very excited to have a
selection of poets from
the new book, The Best
New Poets of 2012.
It is my personal pleasure
to introduce
our first poet today.
Daniel Meltz is a Googler, and
is on my team, and I'm pleased
as punch that we are here, and
talking about some of the
stuff he likes to do when
he's not doing the
stuff that he does.
So thank you, everyone.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Daniel Meltz.
DANIEL MELTZ: Thank you,
and thanks, Kate, for
arranging all this.
I'm going to introduce the first
poet, but we're going to
go into alphabetical order.
So the first poet is Elizabeth
T. Gray, Jr. She's a poet,
translator, and corporate
consultant.
Her translations of Iran's major
mystical poet Hafez-e
Shirazi, died in 1389, were
published by White
Cloud Press in 1995.
Poems and translations from
Persian and Tibetan have
appeared or are forthcoming in
the "Kenyan Review," "Beloit
Poetry Journal," the "Harvard
Review," "The Cimmaron
Review," "Poetry International,"
[INAUDIBLE],
"The New Orleans Review,"
"The New Haven Review,"
[INAUDIBLE], and "Provincetown
Arts."
She has a JD from Harvard Law
School, and an MFA from Warren
Wilson College.
She lives in New York
City, and she's at
elizabethgrayjr.com.
Elizabeth T. Gray.
ELIZABETH T. GRAY:
Thanks, Dan.
And thank you all for having
us and sharing
your lunch with us.
It's been really fun
to meet the other
poets in the anthology.
And I'm just really pleased
to be here today.
I'm going to start with
one of the poems
that's in the anthology.
It's called Albania.
I grew up at the height of the
Cold War in the '50s and the
'60s, and of all the communist
countries, Albania was the
most mysterious.
I mean, you just couldn't find
out anything about it.
It wasn't on the hit list
of evil countries.
But my first passport said, if
you take this passport into
Albania, it will
become invalid.
So time passed.
Fast forward.
In the year 2005, my husband
and I were on a boat,
homeschooling our kids
in the Mediterranean.
And as we were going up the west
coast of Greece, I looked
at the charts.
And there was Albania.
So this was written
after we'd left.
We were heading up the
coast of Croatia.
"Albania.
On Sunday, I went to Albania.
No one understood clearly at
first why I or anyone would go
to Albania, except my father,
who knew at once.
Because before, you couldn't
go to Albania.
It had never occurred
to me before to
actually go to Albania.
For years, it was there,
a Mars, the
ultimate hole in the atlas.
Albania.
Our government said you couldn't
go to Albania.
Passports self-vaporized,
I thought,
if you want to Albania.
It was like the Middle
Ages with missiles,
over there in Albania.
And sometimes China, Albania.
But then it was Sunday,
40 years later.
And I was right there.
I was right next to Albania.
There's a thin strait
and small islands.
You pay a ferryman to
cross to Albania.
Before, people who tried to swim
away were shot by men in
trenches and towers
guarding Albania.
Everyone was surprised when
I left alone for Albania.
Given her history, were you
worried when your mother went
off to Albania?
No-- well, maybe a little,
they said.
She never mentioned Albania.
When I came back, everybody
asked about Albania.
They said, what did you
see in Albania?
I began to reply.
But that was enough
of Albania.
Perhaps it was hard for them,
the idea of Albania.
Maybe they never
had an Albania.
They weren't panicked.
They didn't ask, what
will we do, now that
you can go to Albania?
It's been a few days now.
It's as if nothing happened, as
if I never went to Albania.
The chart shows two ports and
several small harbors.
But from this far offshore,
there are no lights anywhere
along the coast of Albania.
And as we move north, somewhere
to starboard, steep
and with snow, is Albania."
I'm also thrilled that this poem
is actually about to be
translated into Albanian by
my new friend, [INAUDIBLE]
Kalusche, who read the poem.
And now I've been introduced
to all this Albanian
literature, and Albanians.
And New York is full,
and Facebook is full
of all these Albanians.
And it's just an astonishing
introduction to a country that
I never thought actually
existed.
I'm a translator of classical
Persian poetry, and studied in
Iran and Afghanistan and
Pakistan, mostly in the '70s,
some in the '80s.
So the next poem moves east a
little in terms of geography.
On my first trip east,
hitchhiking from Istanbul to
Kathmandu, I traveled for the
first time across that
geography with my first
devastating true love.
And this poem is a poem
written to him later,
obviously, that speaks directly
to him, but draws on
a tradition in Islamic poetry
which we really don't have.
It's using poems as pre-battle
jihadist exhortations or
curses against the enemy.
And some of the lines, I
confess, are stolen.
They were stolen from a document
that was posted on an
Al Qaeda website in 2005 called
An Ultimatum to the
Shiites and Crusaders, by Abu
Musab al-Zarqawi, who was
running Al Qaeda in
Iraq at the time.
So it's called, "In The Alleyway
of the Beloved." And
it starts with a verse
from the Koran.
Here's the Koran [INAUDIBLE].
"Whatever vow you vow, surely
Allah knows it.
And the evildoers will
have no help.
It was no dream back then, in
the high cold between the
mountains, at the rim of the
gravel pits west of the city,
watching the dog fights, the
men with whips taking bets,
where we swore to it, and again,
later, we swore to it,
where the money changer's
boy brought us
tea on a copper tray.
I kept faith, kept to faint goat
tracks in snow, became
both wraith and arrow,
embedded, a
blade end in your rib.
You remember, there in your
broad California, how dust
hangs like breath or gold in
the air here in the land of
the two rivers.
In this maze of narrow lanes,
there will be no mercy.
That word in my throat
has been slit.
You will be given to
drink from the
various goblets of death.
It is written.
He who warns is excused."
Moving from that
cheerful note--
it took me 30 years
to write that.
I hope someday he
gets to read it.
The last poem is from a
manuscript that is forthcoming
from Four Way Books,
where Victoria, our
next reader, works.
It's going to be published
in the spring of 2015.
It's a series of poems loosely
based on the adventures of a
bunch of young travelers and
hippies who are traveling
through India.
And in this one, Blake, who's
a Brit, is sharing with a
group of his friends, one of
whom's name is Sarah, a way
cool new tantric strange
bizarre visualizate and
meditation technique that
he's heard about.
"Blake was talking
up a new rite.
You go alone to a really scary
place, spread out your skin,
cook your body parts up in your
iron pot, add specific
syllables, summon the demons,
feed them, and you're free.
You have to get it just right.
So he went over the invitees
and ingredients again--
dandling lung, aorta, liver,
femur, dipthong.
Brad said nothing, but Nadia
offered the room a few more
inches of arm.
I never have to call
them, said Sarah.
Two of them are always there,
an opaque, imperceptibly
moving surface that stretches
away on every side, and
betrayal for which there is no
evidence but of which I am
entirely certain.
Doesn't love dismember
our selves?
Every curve and secretion,
offered up?
Afterward, you pick up
your skin and go
home." Thank you.
Let me introduce Victoria.
Victoria Lynne McCoy holds an
MFA in poetry from Sarah
Lawrence College.
Her works appeared in "Boxcar
Poetry Review," "Used
Furniture Review," "PANK," and
"Union Station Magazine,"
among others.
A member of the louderARTS
Project, Victoria lives in
Brooklyn and works for
Four Way Books.
Welcome, Victoria.
VICTORIA MCCOY: Hi.
Thanks, Kate, for setting this
all up and having us.
And thank you for sharing
your lunch hour with us.
I'll start by reading the
poem from the anthology,
"Self-Portrait in Unfinished
Letters."
"Dear, the Gulf is bleeding
black again.
They say they'll fix it.
They say Claude Chabrol is dead
for the first time today.
September 12th, and church
bells through
the courtyard window.
I meant to see more of his
films while he was alive.
Barreling down Pacific Coast
Highway, what was that song?
Do you remember what Alison
sounds like sitting shotgun?
Dear, I quit vegetarianism
last month.
Remember when the teacher said,
I'm too old to protest?
The largest picture on the front
page of the paper is a
man crossing Bryant Park with
a mannequin under arm.
They said they'd fix it.
A city of moths to the
tent-white sheen of celebrity.
I try to leave her
out of this one.
Alison, a choir of whispers
in the dark.
Dear, they decided not to burn
the Koran yesterday.
You've always liked it
better when there's
a they in the story.
I've lost faith in
my own impact.
The Nile is drowning in
100 tons of gasoline.
And Alison is dead for the
1,717th time when I wake.
There's a fire under the
earth they can't fix.
Dear, [FRENCH]
in a near empty theater, my
appendages haunted with so
many almosts.
I've forgotten her face for
the third time today.
A sunken-in man on the subway
sings about a city built
entirely of instruments
that make no sound.
The train doors open, their
ghost-bright mouths a calling.
I'll go anywhere the sirens
can't find me."
This next poem is borrowed from
a Japanese form called
the zuihitsu.
That's a sort of collage-like
poem of fragments.
And it means the moving brush.
So it's after Kimiko Han.
"The Body Breakable."
"I watch the lifeguards clasp
hands, a human rake, wade into
the white wash for the body of
a girl who never surfaced.
Somewhere an ocean is
unbroken by rain.
My limbs, furious with sleep,
now the night is beginning to
secede from Brooklyn.
The line that has haunted me.
You ought to wake up with
your mouth full of pity.
I am constantly falling
in love with the
impossibility of a thing.
Again, the knee splits open.
Autumn is one long lesson in
what makes the body breakable.
Some nights, there is a cliff.
Others, a slight mattress shift
under some invisible
weight at my back.
A siren croons its lullaby
from the sea of passing
headlights.
Her name has erected a glass
cathedral around me.
Reading again today about
how Zeus once split
the humans in half.
Ruined cities.
Are we defined by what
is missing?"
And this next poem is called
"Aubade In Pieces."
"Even as I deliver my body from
the subway's tenebrous
mercy, I cannot unknow this.
Each time daylight invades our
limbs, the sun marching its
restless armies up the sheets,
my love will put entire states
between us, and there's no
telling when the map will
tesseract itself to
bring him back.
Always his breath that first
breaks me, his chest a hum of
lightning bugs, lethal
little darlings.
His fingers swarm my thighs.
He leaves teeth prints
to miss him by.
Praise this skin, its miracle
cells, their blessed
forgetfulness.
Under my pillow, a Mason jar
where I collect my name each
time it burns his mouth open.
Fireflies in the summer
porch of him.
I pin their wings down.
I sing to them of the hour
before the wolf comes.
Still Life With Geese
in the Water.
On the border between
Pennsylvania and New Jersey,
the geese gather behind the
bridge's concrete legs to keep
from carrying away
with the current.
The river, lightsome and
long, and the horizon
a great mouth calling.
I recognize the voice.
I am not afraid to be dead.
Only of the act of dying.
My favorite first date was a
surprise helicopter ride--
an aerial tour of Long Beach
Harbor, which I'd known from
the ground all my life.
I've always loved heights.
I think I'd enjoy the falling
before the body breaks.
I left the small bird contorted
on the grass, soft
landing place below the window
it tried to fly through when
it tired of all that
possible sky.
I'd like to know what's
on the other side.
I scrounge in my purse for the
pills to stop the jackhammer
behind my eyes.
I think my sight is failing.
The stop lights have all grown
coronas, and the time blurs in
its black box.
A cyst blooms between my wrist
bones like a promise.
This body you will someday
forgo me completely.
The metacarpals parting in my
hand when I write, a sharp
piercing up my arm that
might be mercy."
And this is my last poem.
Again, thank you all
for being here.
"Self-Portrait as Odysseus.
If there is wreck in me, let
it be anchor and all.
Oh, you beautiful ones with your
jackal call, the steel
trap of you and your meadow
starred with flowers, you
honey throated ghosts, ripples
in the windless hours.
My dead are waiting
at the bottom.
Sing the bees free of me
that I may listen.
Sing the wound clean
out of the skin.
I come to you lying down in
my petal thin excuses.
You already know my name.
Sing me soft boned.
Sing me home, you with the
map of the unknown
carved in your palms.
Untie me from grief's
tall mast.
See how it's made
a gully of me.
Oh, you gods of relief,
let the water in."
And our next poet will
be Daniel Meltz.
Daniel Meltz is a technical
writer at Google.
As a younger man, he taught
geometry to the deaf, and
WordPerfect to the blind.
He lives in midtown Manhattan
between a beauty parlor and a
nail salon.
His work has been published in
"American Poetry Review,"
"upstreet," "Mudfish," "Audio
Zone," [INAUDIBLE], "Assisi,"
"40 Ounce Bachelors," and
"CrossConnect." Please welcome
Daniel Meltz.
DANIEL MELTZ: Thank you.
Thanks for coming.
OK, this first poem is
from the anthology.
It's called "Intrinsic
Marimbas."
"I had 45 minutes, so I went to
my favorite shoelace store
on East 59th, where the shoelace
boy's always flirting
with the hot cashier in
her skintight top.
They're appealing, although they
don't exactly take me in.
And then it's out into the
street again, where nobody's
sure if it's drizzling enough
to haul out the umbrella.
The crowds are staggering.
The tourists in the glass apple
elevator, the arm in arm
Brazilians, the jaywalking
bullies, the women in
flip-flops, toes serenely
gripping.
The man and woman in gorgeous
sweaters and matching tans,
emerging from Bergdorf's, door
held, two big doormen with
creased smiles and
no sense of pomp.
I was here a couple months
ago at Doug's suggestion.
It was drizzling then, too.
He loves that little shoelace
store where they also do
shines and repairs, of course.
He was always saying of course,
which I hated at first.
It seemed so condescending, but
then I came to understand
his odd expressions
of delight.
I do not miss him, but I miss
the way he showed up jumping
and took off bouncing and looked
at me as if we were
jackhammering sidewalk, worker
and foreman, deep into sex.
But the crowds were exciting,
the drama of the criss-cross.
And then a walk through
Crate and Barrel.
I bought a pillow,
black and green.
Two men helped me, one large,
one small, both Filipino.
A double barreled cruise
that only added to
the jolt of the purchase.
They put my pillow in a see
through bag, which made me a
little embarrassed.
I thought, let me take
58th back west to get
away from the people.
But after a block,
I was bored.
I wanted to see the trees, so I
circled around and into the
park where everything was
shockingly green from all the
rain of this week, and the
barks were black--
greens and blacks, as exciting
as the black and green of the
pillow I'd bought.
The lindens and flowers smelling
like Juicy Fruit,
soil, sopping, mossy, quiet.
The dark pane of quiet so close
to all the traffic.
An awesome shart with spandrel
branches and stained glass
leaves and fog in
the spandrels.
The fog's been settled in among
the building tops for
days, so unusual in midtown.
You can't see the top
of Time Warner.
It disappears into the fog,
along with the top of the
ugliest trump in the world, and
the memory of a boat ride
in the snow.
Later, there he was, Doug, in
front of CBS, whispering my
name before he slipped
inside."
So this next one--
I'm not really used to reading
poetry in public.
This one is called "On A Murphy
Bed Mattress Full of
Easter Egg straw."
"I would write and the lines
would spool out of me.
It was a physical need to keep
defining myself, but I never
felt defined.
I filled notebooks, I covered
walls, I hung a
pen around my neck.
That was the strangest.
The pen around my neck.
I counted out the beats of
the words on my fingers.
I broke the thesaurus.
I consulted the forms.
Pyramids, houses, concertos, pup
tents, anything to give a
shape to my thoughts that ran
screaming from the feelings my
thoughts turned up in rampages
of anxiety and unbroken hours
of unconsidered scribble.
When I had no money, I scotch
taped notebooks together and
wrote poems and plays and serial
comic novels, starting
from the back next to the inside
cover that in a store
bought version, would show
a multiplication table.
When I had a little money,
I bought a computer.
When I had a little more,
I started watching TV.
It was while channel surfing
that I saw it all clearly.
In the crooked smile of an
anime warrior, in Anne
Bancroft's persistent finger
spelling, in the pitiless
debating of the whiners and
the chest beaters, on the
faces of the chubby kids turning
cartwheels on the
Disney Channel, in the AIDS
reports, in Mike Wallace's
wrinkles, in Barbara Streisand's
tears, in the
squalor after the flood,
in the hubris after the
landslide, in a softened
Archie Bunker, in a
confrontational Edith, in
the wind in the trees.
I saw it.
I took a picture of it with
my cell phone camera.
Mike's face morphing
into Barbara's.
God's feet slipping into a
sinister pair of slingback
energetics.
It's in the lines, see.
The lines that differentiate the
heads from the curtains,
the ankles from the pantyhose,
the other from the me."
This next poem is called "Just
Outside of Bowler City." And
when I was a kid, there was a
bowling alley in Hackensack,
New Jersey that claimed
to have the most
alleys on the planet.
It had 50 bowling alleys,
50 lanes, I mean.
"Just Outside of Bowler City."
"My first teacher was my father,
a sarcastic figure in
underpants.
He taught me how to idolize
and instigate.
My mother ran from him.
She brushed her hair
til it bounced.
She used the hairbrush
as a weapon.
She loved the smell of the
future, but she never
stepped into it.
My sister showed me her
workbook, a multiplication
table and spelling lists.
She read Black Beauty
aloud to me.
She turned on cartoons, Heckle
and Jeckle, two angry crows.
She told me about her
teachers at school.
The teacher with the swinging
can, the teacher with the
blubbery neck, the one with the
swishing stockings, the
one with the tangerine
lipstick.
We shared a bedroom with
a kidnap window.
We stage whispered at daybreak,
biting the cream out
of cookies.
We broke bobby pins in two, and
scratched every inch of a
crap credenza."
I'm going to read two more.
This one's called
"Nine Lives."
"It's years since I've had an
answering machine, but there
are still many nights I turn the
key in the lock, eager to
play whatever messages were
left while I was working.
At times, I still think the
radio will go off when I turn
out the bathroom light, though
it's even more years since
that was how it functioned.
These are memories like dreams
from a previous life that
flicker in an updraft of mylar
confetti at the back of the
hero waving from his Jeep.
We forget how much we've
changed, but the diarists and
the face blind know.
It's hard for them to remember
and recount their humiliations
on yellowing paper and in the
offended glares of the
forgotten."
This last one is called
"Narcoleptic Karaoke." You
know, some of these I have
expurgated because coworkers
are here, so--
yeah.
There are some things, Greg,
I just could not read to--
I don't know.
But I just took a couple words,
just a couple words.
But anyway, this is "Narcoleptic
Karaoke."
"I used to make lists of the
names of my friends--
John, Larry, Ernest, Jeffrey,
Rick, Gene, Steve, Lee.
Then every couple of days, I'd
rewrite the list on a scrap of
paper, or on a blank
page in my diary.
Over time, the list
would change.
John, Larry, Jeffrey, Mitch,
Gene, Lee, Ellen, Bill.
Sometimes the list was lined
up with my groceries.
Mitch, coffee, John, yogurt,
David, shredded wheat,
Jeffrey, tomato juice.
Or lined up with my groceries
and the movies I'd seen.
Tom, wheat germ, 'A Room With
A View,' Larry, chick peas,
tuna, 'Blue Velvet.'
I used to write down
everything we
talked about in therapy.
You're full of murderous rage.
I can't hear you.
Then I burst into tears.
She's right!
As much verbatim as
I could remember.
A one act play three
times a week.
I wrote down everything I
saw and who I went with.
I recorded record highs and
lows, and the names of the
trees and every penny I spent.
I recorded orgasms, sick days,
days I'd smoked pot, the
length of the movie, the number
of hours since I'd last
seen Howie, since I'd first met
Linwood, since recorded
rain had fallen.
Inches of snow, days above 90,
the 10 most populous, the
driest, the loneliest, the lone
list, the one list, the
on list, the off list.
Eventually, I threw them out.
Eventually, you wake
up startled.
What are you keeping
lists for?
What's with all the
ledger domain?
It wasn't a question of what to
remember, the diving birds
told me, but who to
forget." That's it.
So, our next reader
is Ben Purkert.
His poems have recently appeared
or are forthcoming in
"The New Yorker," "Fence,"
"Denver Quarterly," "The
[? ALL ?]," "DIAGRAM," "New
Orleans Review," "Carolina
Quarterly," "Spoon River Poetry
Review," and elsewhere.
He holds an MFA from NYU, and
is currently completing his
first poetry manuscript,
"One Good."
He is also poetry editor of
Bodega at bodegamag.com.
Please welcome Ben Purkert.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN PURKERT: Thank you, Dan.
These poems will be completely
uncensored.
So just really--
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you, Google, so much.
Thank you to all of you for
making time for poetry
in your busy day.
Thanks also to the University
of Virginia Press, who put
this anthology together.
It's beautiful.
The work is really great.
So I'm appreciative
to them, too.
I'm going to read a
few shorter poems.
This is the one that appears
in the anthology.
It's called "Ode to Stretch
Armstrong."
"Didn't you ever fling him
across the mud room?
All these rules around a body,
how far it can or cannot.
Stretch could land hard,
and never look,
so to speak, thrown.
Like a pronoun, he'd leap
rivers to attach
to something else.
Don't you lose him in the
heat vents by the door.
Somewhere, you can bet, more
of Stretch is being made.
Every moment on the assembly
line is itself assemblage.
Hands gluing on the legs, or
virtually no hands at all,
only the sun, which
is also a machine.
Once a Boy Scout on your block
had eight gold screws inserted
in his shin.
Once on TV, a chopper flew
so low to the earth
it missed it entirely.
U-Haul and the Dream
of Arrows.
A little pink lemonade in
the nick of my thumb.
A little radio static ringing
in my lungs, and each lung
works like a cutout, since the
body can't be everywhere,
can't be all things
to all mirrors.
And with my windows down, I'll
pretend this isn't a U-Haul,
but a huge-ass space bot bearing
me in its gaping
mouth, and the two of us could
toss around ideas for miles.
We could blow by a million signs
lit up, high in the sky
with arrows pointing down.
And I think maybe that's what
sky is, just a whole mess of
incredibly sharp ends.
And the U-Haul has something
he needs to say.
He nearly breaks down
from not saying it."
I decided to read
this next poem.
It felt sort of topical with
the Super Bowl coming up.
I read sort of this horrifying
statistic--
America consumes more than a
billion chicken wings on the
day of the Super Bowl,
more than a billion.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEN PURKERT: Yeah.
That's sort of staggering.
The title of this poem, "Very
Nearly A Billion Wings."
"This Rose Bowl, America will
polish off nearly a billion
wings alone.
Let's start looking at each wing
as one half of a couple
in a movie theater.
Or instead, a dent in the gross
figure of what we can
count on one hand.
A bird less its wings has a span
around five seconds left.
Then, the big game unravels.
One fumble too many.
Loudly, a fan on his barstool
might snap, why are they
cutting to the mascot?
How hard is it to film
the damn field?"
Just three more poems.
So I work in advertising,
branding.
I freelance for a few
different agencies.
So a lot of my work involves
themes relative to
consumerism, and how we sort
of process ads, and the
relationship to the mind.
So this is a poem
that sort of is
interested in that territory.
"Shown an image of an M&M
wrapper, a subject salivates.
The mind is so easily had.
It's easily the first picked off
deer from a herd, the one
the herd guest would go first,
but never said anything.
And they let the mind
be ravaged.
This way, they might
stand a chance.
And it was so freeing to look
on with no mind, the parts
being eaten in sequence, the
jaws closing on the very slim
bones of the mind.
And when the herd left to roam,
they fell sideways,
their mouths, oh so close,
in the grass."
I don't know what this means,
or if this is only me.
But I feel like I've been seeing
a ton of people that
have butterfly tattoos.
Not just recently, but just sort
of throughout the course
of my life, it's been sort of
this really quiet trope.
I don't know.
So I was interested in that, and
then I decided, instead of
a person with a tattoo of a
butterfly, what about a
butterfly with a tattoo
of a person.
And that sort of ballooned
into whatever this is.
"Tattoo On A Butterfly
Of A Woman."
"The TV's so loud I
start squinting.
I start at the corner of each
eye, pinching it barely enough
to ruffle a bedsheet.
With visible force, the TV
booms, what's coming up next.
And this is distinct
from the future.
I think the future's a tough
skin we always chew.
We even leave some very
light marks on it.
Once, on a date, a butterfly
lifted her wings to me.
She was revealing
some pattern."
And this is the last poem.
Thanks again.
"Love Like A Fork And Knife."
"For weeks, rain bruises the
backyard, where one tree
shines as a proxy for
standing upright.
But a tree can't separate twigs
from leaves, let alone
clouds from passing planes.
And maybe it's both male and
female, so each can't split
from the other, each half rooted
in something hard.
And the tree is no billboard,
but still flashes like one
white hot bulb, soaking up
the electric, and says to
whoever's around, there's
water where I am.
Also some sun here.
It's possible to say things
simply by not dying."
Thank you very much.
And the next and last and very
talented poet we have is
Sophia Starmack.
She received an MA in French
and Francophone literature
from Bryn Mawr College, and is
currently completing an MFA in
poetry at Sarah Lawrence.
She works as a writing teacher
and tutor in New York City.
Sophia.
SOPHIA STARMACK:
Thanks so much.
I'm really excited that I
finished that MFA since this
book was published.
Yeah.
No, it's really important
you can finish things.
Thanks so much.
It's really special
to be here.
The poem in the book is from a
long poem that I wrote, which
is sort of a love story that I
wrote for myself, and also for
the place where I grew up, which
is in Western New York--
a really small village.
So I'm going to start there, and
just keep going and read
you a bit from that
very long poem.
"If I, too, thinks Alice,
then the glacier.
In the beginning, grinding its
fingers, the grit of schist
and granite sticks to its lonely
bone, its white soul to
steer it, a whale bone
whistling north.
If the glacier, thinks Alice,
then I. If I, then the ice.
If I, too, then the mouth of the
river, the mouths of the
dead through my dream.
If I, too, then the rock and the
names carved in the rock.
If I, too, then my mother, her
fringe leather jacket.
If I, too, then the calf, and
the cow's hanging udder.
If I, too, then the field,
each wheat spear turning.
If I, too, then the song, under
the light shaft striking.
If I, too, then each blade
of sun unturning, and the
darkness and the darkness
hollering over the valley and
after 10 millennia, even a
glacier gives up the ghost.
I had forgotten they still made
places, thinks Jo, like
this, when the hot sun slams
back in, her eyelids, the ripe
darkness, the drugstore
softens around her.
What is a drugstore after
all, remembers Jo?
Something about sweet syrup
and chipped ice.
Something about penny candy,
thinks Jo, asking the pimpled
boy behind the counter
for a soda.
The sly ceiling fan unwinding,
dust from hot September.
I'll take it, she says, and
pays for a cherry Coke.
Cherry Coke, please, says
Alice in her sun dress,
sitting on the concrete stoop,
Alice in her feather down,
furs like a blonde coat.
Alice, on the edge of becoming
Alice, drinks like a greedy
wolf from the waxy paper cup,
leaves sweet sweat on the rim.
It's only the strap of a sun
dress in hot September, the
poured cement of an old time
drugstore, the strap of a
sundress, a sun-peeled
shoulder.
Shouldn't you be, asks
Jo, in school?
But Alice holds her eye.
Says nothing.
They sip at Cherry Cokes and
suck the ice, the wax, flakes
on the cup, the skin peels
on the shoulder.
I have become a woman, writes
Alice in her notebook, but
before disappearing through the
greening light it slips,
just the strap of her sun
dress, her peeled skin
shoulder, and Jo, without
thinking, pulls it up.
With the radio down, and the
windows at one with her
thoughts, Jo's got seven
women on her mind.
Seven women like seven stars,
one for each finger of her
left hand, and two for the
invisible fingers of feeling.
One the stories she reaches
out for, two the stories
reaching back.
Seven women, seven stars,
seven sisters, tucked in
Orion's belt.
Jo knows Orion, knows his heavy
shield, buckles against
the night, knows the heavy arms
of his terror, knows the
little knife keeps
tucked close.
Which is more illicit?
A not so little girl in the
street light, or the driver,
home from a guilty errand?
Alice owns the street, tuned
to the night machine, a car
shining approaching, holding
her ground in
the one lane street.
The thrill in her t-shirt,
the dew and the crickets.
Alice knows summer is dying, and
Alice wants to be real in
the headlight, wants to be
touched under her dress by
flakes of light that beam from
the headlights, holds the
unknown gaze of the stranger,
late from work,
or something worse.
They both know the needle
of night time.
Alice spreads herself on the
darkness and bounds into the
arms of the ash tree.
The car slows, and
scuttles by.
They have seen, not
seen, each other.
For everyone knows this town
goes to bed at 9:00.
Back home, the driver considers
the moon, its horns
and its feathers, the orange
disc of its suffering.
Down the hill he steers his
lonely station wagon.
This is the weight of one.
He slides his feet, his leather
clogs and hand-knit
socks, his graying beard
his weakness.
Slumps at the table, leaves
the light untouched.
Upstairs, his wife
breathing, the
children sticky with dreams.
He has a taste at once of frost,
October coming, the
moon dropped pebbles
of ice and trouble.
The driver watched them glitter
off the skin of the
girl made real in
his headlight.
Hands strong and sullen,
he cradles his head.
Alone in the darkness alone, in
the breathing, and winter
to come."
Thank you so much.
Thanks to everyone.